all right I was on the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning you
can find it at david pakman.com slash
reddit and some very interesting
discussions I'll show you just a few
them starting first and foremost with a
conversation about whether you ever just
want to unplug from politics completely
and it's a pretty interesting post from
one of our regular redditors which says
you know every once in a while I
sometimes feel like giving up on the
entire thing and just disconnecting
altogether from news and politics and I
think it's an interesting conversation I
think there's no doubt that certain day
to day political happenings really don't
impact most people at the same time
though I think is important to be an
informed citizen when it comes to voting
when it comes to advocating for what
matters to you and your family into
humanity so yeah I sometimes do get
disillusioned with politics in general
but do I ever say I'd rather I'd rather
just not know anything that's going on
now that doesn't happen to me
well even when I'm on vacations I'm
still reading articles and all that sort
of thing but maybe I'm just in my own
bubble because politics is really my
passion right so a little different for
everyone else passionate Pat passionate
Pat might be a new meme that we will see
okay also from our reddit discussion
forum earlier today opioid epidemic a
very interesting post about the opioid
epidemic and its relation to looking at
drug legalization really good
conversation you can participate in a
david pakman.com slash read it which we
will actually be talking about a little
bit later on in today's program let's
continue
also from the reddit discussion forum a
conversation about cheating in golf a
very very funny post saying I think
you're giving a little I think you're
going a little low here complaining
about Donald Trump cheating and golf
David my grandmother used to cheat in
solitaire and she was a well-respected
honest member of society she was also a
distinguished golfer for her age I'm
sure there's no connection there and
will tolerate no speculation so people
defending Donald Trump's golf cheating
hey I mean if Trump is doing incredible
things for the country we probably
wouldn't even criticize him for that
that would be something that we'd give
of a pass on there's nothing he won't
lie about there's
area where he won't deceive and by the
way he's not accomplishing great things
for the country and also to interesting
new images from the David Pakman show
discussion forum the david pacman meme
as opposed to David Pakman putting my
face inside of the video game pac-man
character Wow nobody's ever made jokes
like that before my entire life I was
never nobody ever mentioned that game no
never this is the first time I've ever
heard that a joke made this meme might
even be better than the miss pac-man
mean hmm although very different yes
completely different and lastly one
other mean related to this week's hatred
mail where a hatred called me David
pecan PA kan and someone repurposing
that into David pecan pe CA and of
course this is a kind of tree nut I
think so yeah okay or you could say
pecan yeah we'll have them I if I'm in
the South I'll definitely say pecan oh
you will and how often is that once okay
so anyway to check out the David pecan
or David pecan meme at david pakman.com
slash read it approaching 5,000 of our
viewers and listeners regularly
participating there